who was more into getting married
you were yeah
every man at home went
you
she is
women in and they're talking marriage is
crazy funny but i was the one that was
more into marriage than my girl really
mm-hmm
yeah but that was the most religion
thing a religious thing yeah yeah it's
also like um i feel like especially here
in this province like
the white people here are heathens and
so as a result the idea of like marriage
and religion oh it's really not that i'm
just saying generally in this province
marriage rates are really low yes yeah
because they're not about that they're
not about that life anymore yeah yeah i
don't think i've ever really been into
marriage like that though i will admit
because i started filming marriages you
know what was kind of cool when people
do their little speeches in front of
friends and family you know like at the
banquet area yeah i always thought those
were kind of cool because it's like a
chance to give people their flowers
you're going to roast or roast a
[ __ ] roasted [ __ ] not
into [ __ ] ethiopian marriages
how are they doing to us
why you making
contemporary that's what the [ __ ] it
is nah look at the romo tribe wedding
[ __ ] dance [ __ ] i know i know
[Music]
oh no it's not even the cousins it's
this [ __ ] because this is what she's
right here you do the woman
[Music]
that is definitely like the ladies thing
but all genders will do the shoulders
thing yeah and they got the beads or the
necklaces and they do that
the others guys watch too many [ __ ]
you think i don't look i don't know
about you [ __ ] i know you i
introduced you to the food so i didn't
know how much you knew
[Music]
[Laughter]
hold on
let me look for it hold on no no no
we're done no [ __ ] this [ __ ] let's keep
on pushing okay you don't get to decide
no no we see lilly no no we're moving on
[Music]
was it your idea
she was where the pressure came from
once we were here the pressure was on
for multiple from multiple angles it
wasn't just you at that point really
wait who family friends
i mean people are always pressing folks
in man to get married yeah have you
heard comments
go ahead and tell them all the time they
always be when you go
yeah yeah
here you go yo when you been with your
girl for so long you start to go so you
go to mom's place your mom always asks
questions you know with her face so
sound like a sober bill cosby
pudding you know i saw my mom recently
you know i went back to hometown to go
see her you know and i get in the car me
and my mom driving
and as we're driving my mom out of
nowhere says
why are you gonna give me kids
i said where did this come from she
hadn't brought this up in a year because
she learned her lesson
she says ah you know
mustafa he's married he has kids i said
what that's my [ __ ]
did i miss something when did he have a
child does he never get a job that's
what i'm saying
she's like i'm jealous i'm jealous i'm
like how do you know that she says i was
on whatsapp and he had picture with chad
i was like that's his niece
mom's doing his mom's do too much i'm
like and then she looked at me she said
ah okay okay but when you're gonna give
me child and i got mad at this [ __ ] for
having the wrong picture and having my
mom on whatsapp because
why don't you [ __ ] got jerome and why
is that he helps trump cause i'm not
always oh yeah
you know when you've got a little bit of
a language yeah you need a village to
support
you know sometimes i hit him up like you
can help my mom with this and then you
know that's what good friends are for
and they do the dance yeah yeah
i mean my mom i'll be coming home as
soon as i come in
[Music]
which means come over here and i already
know some [ __ ]
come sit over here in the living room
with you oh it's always something
there's going to be a [ __ ]
discussion i know it's going to doubly
be some [ __ ] if i hear my mom and i
hear other women oh
yeah yes
because there was a woman when other
women look at they sized you up like oh
who could you i got a daughter you know
so they start trying to set [ __ ] up and
you always hear i'm like when my mom do
that my mom did when she did that [ __ ]
then this other woman around you she's
like what was that well you're not
marrying my daughter no [ __ ] i don't
yeah well i mean also you got dreads and
you look the way you do you know you're
not as presentable yeah tattoo you know
me when i had my huge afro was a lot
easier
true my [ __ ] family oh
your parents did love me huh yeah
i told you i thought they hated me after
i broke up with you
or do they still like me now
they sent you christmas gifts you ding
dong i guess
i think the same christmas gifts you
ding dong
and them gifts are better than mine
[ __ ] those aren't parents that still
like it those are parents who still want
you to marry their son
out of all the lovers you've had where
do i rank
the shot time
i mean yeah but i have to think about it
no you don't well you're definitely not
at the top that's what you
confirm like a donkey if women like you
and you the best they want to tell you
they want to tell you like drake tells
it here you go beautiful game
drake made that song forever ago and
this [ __ ] can't keep a single woman
you know he's lying
you know he's like
if one of his first singles you're the
one for me
and this [ __ ] been single for another
10 years banging all these brats renting
out [ __ ] dodger stadium to go on a
date
you're definitely not the best you ever
had what could have possibly saved our
engagement um nothing
because i didn't have the capacity to
understand
yep
i agree with that i was like a trophy i
was always on the shelf and you would
take me down dust me off to make you
happy for the moment show me off to
whomever and then once the moment passed
or once you retired you would put me
back on the shelf yep that's not how you
deserve to be treated i know but for
some reason i was all right to settle
the dot
why didn't it work out
this is an easy one do you want to
answer this question oh absolutely oh
absolutely because it's all coming it
all comes from me at the time i didn't
understand how unhappy i was mostly
because we weren't communicating and all
that was coming from me she was
communicating with me i was not
communicating with her eventually this
kept driving a bigger and bigger wedge
between us and eventually i was just
like man i just want to feel like
somebody else cares about me and went
out and found somebody else to sleep
with he cheated yeah it was great by
great i mean i don't even remember who
the person was
yeah it was great but i think this is
what like decent accountability looks
like you know
not putting in on her saying he [ __ ]
yeah up for him good for him
you know good for him i mean yeah he
cheated and cheated on the woman he was
supposed to marry and you know the rest
of life and betrayed her trust and all
that good stuff but to accountability
got to give credit where it's due
see but if you were a high value man it
would just be exercising options and you
would have never done anything that's
wrong so just always remember that
high value man that's right
all you broke people are watching right
now this isn't for you
why don't you remember that first
because it didn't mean anything to me
it's just like it was truly just a
meaningless experience to me and
it is the biggest regret of my entire
life what do you think about that when
people say it was a meaningless
experience what do you think it's a
possible thing
a lot of people can't understand that
why would you do something like that why
would you boom
but a lot there's a lot of reasons yeah
just like you said it once uh back then
the people
genders cheat for different reason
ultimately like general generalization
you know i mean yeah doesn't mean i
didn't mean the thing
but yeah
yeah i mean it's just like ladies
sometimes i ask like how do guys just
constantly have like meaningless sex and
it's like it's like masturbating
sometimes sometimes you need to clean
the pipes that's it
doesn't mean anything doesn't
yeah but you're betraying this girl's
trust of course the implications of the
actions far more that way but the action
itself is just
that's just the same thing i've seen
guys how can you guy has how can you
guys have meaningless sex
you're you're betraying the person that
you live in is it you're right you're
absolutely right you're absolutely 100
right how can you be intimate with
someone that you're not having
meaningless sex and then just rattle
about it to all your girlfriends
you're betraying their stress
doing the same thing you're betraying
the person's stress by just telling what
you're supposed to be in confined with
other people it's different it's a
different story but at the end of the
day you tell the stuff that were in the
intimacy of people are you comparing
cheating to gossiping
um yeah i just did
all right ladies i was doing that face
for y'all cause i know that's how you
guys are looking at preach right now
should never forget i understand you
ladies all right next time you think
somebody's a misogynist
but they already know they already know
black women though
no please when was the last time we had
sex describe it in all its glory
i'll take a half shot for the second
half of it
but that one are you snort
it's a divorce that's nasty
no no i can't take nobody outside in
public
no brother that's embarrassing
and that's a high value man i'm taking
you to like a public function you know
talking to ceo
you're not high value
my bank account disagrees
i hope so
no but seriously the whole snorting
thing has such a i knew one girl was
like really attractive but she snorted
so much and it would just kill the vibe
because she'd be looking at her like
damn i should she was
so loud too you'd be like damn why am i
thinking of bacon right now it's just it
was uh literally that was literally
yesterday it was yesterday
but yeah
really
it's really vanilla sex nothing too
interesting so you two are sleeping with
each other
yes so we are and this is just recent
but we're not technically together or
anything like that for me personally i
think it's because it's like i know you
dating apps scare the [ __ ] out of me
people can be scumbags and it's just
like i know who you are and there's a
comfort in that
so i think that's why we're just kind of
like figuring it out we're trying to
figure it out
y'all [ __ ] that's it i think you want
the man wants to get back with her but
she's not she's not about it it's not
about that life she [ __ ] with you
because you're convenient yep which is
fine yep but you see the way he's
leaning in all the way on the table and
this way she's just chilling backwards
man listen once a woman starts to
feeling different about you is there
already a rap just keep it pushing how
did your friends and family react when
we broke our engagement
oh [ __ ] yeah my mom was pissed
oh my mom was [ __ ] furious
i think dad was sad for me but at the
same time he could sympathize with you
because he did the same exact thing to
my mom yeah but she stuck around and
that's why they still married
what you don't find it funny
that what her mom was willing to
tolerate and stay married in the
daughter isn't and then she kind of
looks to them like oh that's a good
relationship
is this interesting
it's like i'm not mad i think everyone
should draw the lines if you're not okay
with it don't be like
but there's like a certain interesting
thing where it's like
you know sometimes people say stuff like
oh i want a marriage like my parents but
you don't always know what happened
within that marriage or some of the dark
secrets like absolutely
do not know until you come into a
certain age man listen because my mom's
my homie now like we friends right you
and your mom yeah we have different
conversations there's a point where you
go from child to yeah to a friend yeah
you said a child but you're a friend now
so they have different conversations
they start to let you in on family
secrets things that you're like he did
who the what and the juice the yo listen
my favorite the juice days of our lives
my name i'm talking about like i can't
even say it i can't it's like
we will go to jail what would be what
would be the name of your of your uh
of your soap opera days of our lives
voodoo spells and money
that sounds like a good book that sounds
like a dungeon in the dragons voodoo
spells their money yeah and what you
learn is like some of the people who
stay together who look like such great
relations to you realize like there's
some dark [ __ ] that happened between
them things that they keep from
everybody and you're like you guys look
so good to me for so long though so just
remember all those great marriages that
you see oftentimes there's some darkness
to it it's not always clean cut
what would it take for us to get back
together
uh
i would need to know that you trust me
again
in that capacity and i don't know what
that would that would entail hey man
i'ma also say this if someone says they
can never trust you again
you gotta keep it pushing bruh
especially if they hold that [ __ ] over
you you gotta keep i'm not saying that's
what she would do but
you know sometimes people have these
things and they're like man i'm trying
to fight for her trust back and i'm
trying and i'm trying but she just
doesn't want to she said she never will
it's time for you to walk away bruh
don't let her hold the [ __ ] over you you
made the mistake
maybe she forgave you but she's not
willing to move past it and if that's
the case that's okay that's her right
but don't sit there and apology for the
rest of your life
okay and don't make her have to sit
through that and have to make her try to
pretend either just makes you miserable
so
yeah
right because i still understand that
you don't trust me in that regard and i
wouldn't i mean rightfully so uh
so that's like i don't know what i'm
looking for this is kind of why we're in
this uneasy what the [ __ ] are we doing
state yeah
is he crying when you back right now he
is he's trying
i don't know if i belong with you
honestly
i don't again i think we're both trying
to figure that out right now but i still
love you and i still want you to be
happy i don't know
if that's going to be with me or if that
will be with somebody else in the future
if it's with somebody else i hope you
treat them
much better than the way you treated me
[Music]
okay i'm keeping it pushing keep it good
for her good for her she realized that
she couldn't go backwards and she made
her decision so i think i support
anybody who takes care of themselves so
good for her
again good for him for accepting
accountability yeah that's good
sometimes we also romanticize the things
that we had we're like oh man i let go
something good also doesn't mean that
even if you would have held on it would
have come out good
you know the reason why you neglected it
wasn't just in part because you hate
yourself sometimes it's also partially
because you just weren't into that
person
you weren't willing to do the work for
that person
and sometimes you need the next
relationship or the next really good one
to realize like oh yeah that wasn't for
me even though she was a great person
and on paper it sounds great for
whatever reason i could never do the
things in this relationship
that i could do in that one and i think
knowing that that's like a tough thing
for people to stomach and so they they
romanticize
right they with rose tinted glasses they
look at their exes and be like man if i
would have just done this a little bit
better this we would have worked out
it's like nice you're not remembering
the bad stuff you know the same way
sometimes people talk [ __ ] about their
significant others and only do one side
they do that a lot also on the other end
that's what people are saying that's why
i keep on saying don't talk [ __ ] about
your significant other to other
[ __ ]
because at the end of the day we're
going to look at you crooked and side
eye whenever you're gonna go back to
that [ __ ] and post pictures on
the way like
my one and everything and i'm like [ __ ]
that's not what the [ __ ] you was saying
before
no don't don't talk [ __ ] cause we're
only gonna remember the batches you was
talking about about and we're gonna come
back you're gonna go back to that person
now you look stupid and they definitely
look stupid don't talk [ __ ]
about your significant other to other
people
it's really one-sided you're frustrated
you want to vent out doesn't matter we
don't see the other side not two of you
look stupid you deserve each other
mm-hmm idiots
is there anything else you want to say
no i'm good sure
okay
with that we're gonna end this video let
us know what you guys think in the
comments you don't like my dance bruh
[Music]
you
foreign
[Music]